she claims she's gonna fix the world how
do you know she won't because she is
clearly a raging narcissist whose
ambition knows no limits its use literal
humors anyone who seeks to attain the
power of a god must be prevented at all
costs from the table welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my Watchmen episode 9 video for the
finale so much stuff happened and
there's so much stuff coming up this
week if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
will do top 10 WTF and Easter eggs as we
go along careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet starting
with number 10 to flashback to Lady
trues origin story in the title of the
episode so the title was see how they
fly which is obviously a reference to
the squid at the end of the episode the
way the Ozymandias was able to save the
world once more and it's one of the
verses from the Beatles cover song that
they played over the end of the episode
see how they fly but we get Lady trues
origin story we find out who her mother
was she was a person working for awesome
man Diaz inside his Karnak facility
during the events of the original comic
book series she hates the servitude so
she steals one of his vials inseminates
herself the big painting that she was
staring at when she said fu Ozymandias
is actually a picture of Alexander the
Great he referenced it later in the
episode lady true told him the truth
about what happened because her mother
told her the truth the picture of
Alexander behind which you have all of
your seed that you stored in that
special fridge I don't know what I was
expecting from the father/daughter ness
of it all but the apple doesn't fall far
from the tree like he references it
takes one to know one calling her an
incredible narcissist in probably the
worst person ever to take dr.
Manhattan's power so when he admits that
at the end of the episode is sort of him
admitting to his faults even though he's
still an [ __ ] to the end but then
number nine the flashback to 2008 before
dr. Manhattan had come back to visit
Ozymandias with her explaining her plan
revealing herself to him we get a little
more context for his relationship with
Robert Redford he won't take my calls
said he would have won the election even
without my help this is the version of
Ozymandias that felt like he had fallen
on hard times nobody cared about him he
couldn't tell them the truth I'm the
person that saved the world and nobody
can know but if it wasn't clear
everything that lady true did after this
was on her own like she says at the end
of the episode I wanted you to see that
I could do this coming from nothing
because he literally left her nothing
and she still wound up buying his
company later in life remember they said
the Ozymandias disappeared in lady true
mysteriously just bought his company out
from under him so presumably she left
his Karnak base then went to set out and
make her fortune make all the money that
it took to make her special quantum
device to take dr. Manhattan's power but
along the way also accumulated the
wealth necessary to buy his company out
of spite so she didn't really need his
company she was just buying it to prove
that she could but we get the reveal of
what really happened with the satellite
in him leaving the message with the dead
bodies she claims five years from now
our satellites gonna be over Europa
taking pictures of dr. Manhattan
presumably but she didn't know
eventually what would happen with
Ozymandias being teleported there by dr.
Manhattan so number seven Ozymandias
escapes from the moon so she gets the
message a couple years go by remember it
takes a couple years for all these
things to happen so I think one of the
better reveals is that he's actually
been that statue in her garden this
whole season presumably for a year or
more so when the ship came back she just
wheeled him in and stuck him there and
then only unthought him right before the
finale so this whole season he's just
been sitting there chilling out I saw a
lot of you have that theory in the
comments that Ozymandias was that person
in the statue and that's where he's been
technically you're not wrong but he was
also back on Jupiter it's just that he's
been frozen there for a little while
love the scene with him in the
gamemaster was I worthy opponent no you
definitely were not but you did put on a
hell of a show he straight-up catches
the bullet just like he did during the
original comic series they also did that
moment during the Watchmen movie we get
the full reveal that his message was
saved me daughter which is paying off
that moment from their flashback when he
said I will never ever call you daughter
and I offer you nothing he went full
Ozymandias by the end of the episode
quoting the end times the end is nigh my
friend talking to the newspaper man I
also love the funny moments that they
had to where do people think that
awesome Andy's has been this whole time
oh they think he ran off to the jungle
which I also think is the writers
winking at him being stuck in that
little garden in the golden statue but
number 6 the 7th cavalry captures dr.
Manhattan so this sort of a carryover
from last week's episode the time
between last week's episode in this
episode overlaps a little bit
there were several evil guys
speechifying moments during the episode
from lady true and from senator akane
same type of villain monologue just
coming from different people and in both
instances someone tried to stop them
mid-sentence just a get on with it I
don't care what you have to say just do
whatever it is that you're going to do
Lory tries to make fun of Senator Keynes
dr. Manhattan underwear you know you
look ridiculous in that even though he's
just going on and on and on about how
great he's going to be once he gets all
this power when lady true is villain
monologuing it's the Chiefs Widow that
just tells her just get on with it if
you're gonna kill us go ahead and kill
us but number 5 they activate the device
but it winds up liquefying senator keen
and it activates a teleport that lady
Tru engineered to take them back to the
site of the original massacre in Tulsa
lady Tru could have used her device
anywhere but she's trying to bake all
this deep meaning and mythology into
what she's doing like she's literally
trying to turn herself into a god they
actually reference it later because when
she's sort of looking up getting ready
to take his power there's the image of
Jesus Christ on the cross right next to
her in frame so Ozymandias as he says
takes one to know one
she is a true narcissist in this moment
also make note of some of the things
that dr. Manhattan says when this is all
going on so his mind is sort of racing
all over the place he says that it's
really hard to be present because of the
way the cage works they revealed that
the cage itself is made from all the
melted watch batteries that they were
collecting at the beginning of the
season because that's the only thing
that could contain and block his power
most of the lines of dialogue that he
has are actually quotes from the
original events of the comic book way
back in 1985 but he also implies at the
military at some point later in the
timeline tried to get him to go to
Afghanistan presumably because of all
the oil which seems like a very obvious
reference to the Bush administration in
the actual war in Iraq just a little
while ago when he tells Angela not to
touch the light he's actually referring
to the light that's coming off of him
the unfiltered quantum energy because it
liquefied senator keen so don't touch it
because you will also to be liquefied
number 4 lady true eviscerates the
leadership of Cyclops so this is
obviously a big deal but it was part of
the bargain that will Angela's
grandfather made with lady true it was
the justice that he was supposed to get
so he made a deal with the devil as he
later implied
but that deal itself was dr. Manhattan's
original idea that's why they referenced
the flashback because dr. Manhattan
engineered this whole plan because he
saw the future and knew how everything
was going to play out number three
though Ozymandias new plan to save the
world
I'll give her a rerun he makes fun of
her making fun of his reruns because
when she comes in 2008 she's like you've
been playing the same old tune this
entire time what if we came up with a
completely different plan for saving the
world so when he says rerun he's just
doing the squid plant again like more
squid a rerun of his previous plan only
this time he's freezing them and using
them sort of like bullets just breaking
everything in their path typical
Ozymandias love his quote when Laurie's
like do you think we can save Jon he's
like nope he's definitely already dead
by now back at Ground Zero you also
noticed Lady trues mother who now knows
her true origin story oh I'm her mother
actually starts to help Angela and she's
in a cop car at the end so she might be
playing things like she's completely
innocent so there's potential there for
her to take up Lady trues legacy because
now she's gonna inherit everything that
she owns because unless someone tells
the truth no one's gonna find out that
she's actually secretly a clone but
technically I think by next of kin she
would inherit everything of Lady trues
number two lady true dies and then
Ozymandias gets arrested by Laurie is
also implied that they'll eventually try
to arrest President Robert Redford
because he knew the truth of what
happened in New York this is sort of a
mirror for the ending of the original
comic book series the truth in
Rorschach's journal about what
Ozymandias did what would happen if the
truth got out love the moment in the
theatre - that sort of brings it back
around to the first episode because
remember outside in the square is the
site of the original massacre and inside
the theater where the Oklahoma play has
been playing this is finale on the
sticker that just referenced to the
season finale but they also play the
song from Oklahoma when they walk out of
the theater but this is the theater in
the exact seat that he sat and watching
bass Reeves the marshal of Oklahoma in
that very first flashback at the
beginning of the season the reason why
night owls ship is there I guess is
because it's implied that he either left
it there when they originally came in
the comic series to stop him where at
some point later night owl came back to
Karnak to try and do something and then
left it there they have that funny
moment were awesome and ia's gets really
upset at the thought that he's going to
be arrested it's the same basic
speech that he gave the clones when they
tried to put him on trial only now the
twist is he'll be on trial again but
it'll be real and the consequences will
be real lookin'-glass just whacks him
over the back of the head that guy talks
too much obviously number one WTF is
angela eating dr. Manhattan's egg though
presumably gaining his powers the reason
why they didn't actually show you that
happening by her foot hovers over the
water then they slammed accredits is
because that scene is meant to be a
direct mirror for the last scene of the
comic book series with the hand hovering
over war shacks journal leaving you
wondering if it's ever gonna be
published they did a really good job
editing the scene with the flashbacks
that Angela had asking him back in
Saigon oh so you could put your powers
into this little egg I could eat the egg
and then I could walk on water as far as
them continuing this story in answering
that question Damon Lindelof said that
this story was designed as a one season
one and done thing he did acknowledge
that HBO could decide to continue the
story if they wanted into season two but
for all intents and purposes this was
meant to be a beginning middle and end
all contained in season one people asked
Damon Lindelof if he would ever reveal
the identity of lube man he said no just
like hooded justice was never revealed
in the original comic series we don't
intend on officially revealing who lube
man was he kind of confirmed that it was
agent Pete though when he said that
there would be one final PD pedia entry
overall I actually think that episode 8
is probably a better episode of the
television show than the actual finale
but I am happy that they answered all
those questions and I feel like you know
all the things you need to know to guess
what actually happens after this
Ozymandias probably eventually wound up
going to jail
Angela probably really did get some of
dr. manhattan's powers as to whether or
not she's as powerful as dr. Manhattan I
think is open to speculation though
everyone post her theories in the
comments below if we have any big
questions I'll try to answer them in the
comments starwars rise of Skywalker is
out this weekend I'll be posting my
non-spoilery review on Wednesday but
they'll also be releasing the
mandalorian episode 7 a couple days
early on Wednesday as well so that video
will also post on Wednesday as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see all the videos when I post
them while you wait for everything click
here for my Mandalorian episode 6 video
and click here for my new baby yoda
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight